ist die pille noch zeitgemäß wäre dazu
eine klare meinung hat ist frank h frei
ich bin autorin ich halte es nicht für
zeitgemäß dass wir so wenig darüber
wissen was verhütung mit uns machen und
das die ganze bürde auf dem menschen mit
unteres liegt und zwar völlig
selbstverständlich sie trifft auf matt
berliner heinzl sie ist der meinung dass
die pille für viele die beste lösung ist
ich bin klinische sexologin und
sexualpädagogin ich glaube dass es
dringend braucht ist eine differenzierte
auseinandersetzung also nicht nur dieses
spiel ist nur scheiße oder pille ist
quasi das mittel für alles weil haben
keine ahnung auf wen sie treffen und was
heute passiert
wir haben schon mal gemeinsam podcast
aufgenommen
wir schicken zwei menschen mit
unterschiedlichen meinungen einen tag
lang auf einen roadtrip umstellen ihnen
am ende die frage trefft ihr euch in der
mitte gibt es eine grauzone
[Musik]
sehen wo wir hinfahren ich habe überlegt
eine kläranlage werden die witzig wegen
dem ganzen den hormonen im grundwasser
anderen medikamenten und von der pille
oder wir beschäftigen uns mit dem thema
abtreibung und nach dem motto das
erspart ihr schlimmeres wie ist
eigentlich deine erfahrung also hast du
auch schon als junge frau die pille
genommen ja
ich habe sie selber fisch also ich hab
mit 14 verschrieben bekommen ein
präparat das mittlerweile gar nicht mehr
zugelassen ist am markt also die zweite
präparat hatte ich dann echt lange das
hat gut gepasst beim ersten hatte ich
noch sechs monaten hatte ich keine
blutung und dann war es so blutungen der
hölle kreuzschmerzen unterbauchschmerzen
einmal und dann will ich präparat
gestiegen und das hat dann super gepasst
und als ich die abgesetzt habe ging es
auch wieder sofort also ich muss sagen
für mich was eine gute möglichkeit in
der zeit jetzt kann mir gerne dann auch
darüber sprechen so was was bedeutet das
für für andere geschlechter dass männer
das nicht lernen
man lernt sich nicht mehr zu begreifen
als reproduktive körper dabei gehören
jetzt zu einer schwangerschaft und
geburt und auch für jegliche fragen von
familienplanung mindestens zwei und ich
finde es so also so 50er dass wir immer
noch in diesem mainz drin stecken dass
es besser ist die frau wurde das alleine
und anzunehmen und ich hab auch dann
liegen auch so geschlechter
stereotypische
vorurteile zu grunde dass wir sagen ja
aber wenn dann sind doch eh wir sind eh
so verantwortungslos oder so
[Musik]
wir sitzen liebe einrichtung dem auto
größte was ich jetzt auch unser weg noch
befindet ist paderborn
in paderborn vorbei
wolfhagen ja so ganz falsch liegt
magdalena damit licht
erhalten
bekommen in einem jugendhaus
er weißt du was uns zusammenbringt und
welche möglichen diskussions und
konfliktpotenziale ich habe gehört
gesprächen über die pille ich habe eine
klare meinung dazu die pille ist
zeitgemäß man muss gucken wie sie
gegeben wird bzw eine zu welchem zwecke
sie gegeben wird insofern hat sie ihre
daseinsberechtigung immer noch aber sie
muss halt mit bedacht verordnet werden
also für mich ist die pille einfach
erstmal medikament darüber hinaus muss
mal schauen für wen ist die geeignet für
wenig und davon machte ich auch abhängig
sie verorten oder nicht wisst ihr was
wir für eine beratung bekommen
empfängnisverhütung beratung pro quartal
sind acht euro pro kopf pro patienten
und ich habe eine prüfzeit ist
unglaublich 67 minuten die darf ich also
investieren für eine vergütungsberatung
und wenn man als praxis wirtschaftlich
arbeiten will ist das auch so eine
realistische zahl und da ist natürlich
leicht gesagt hier nehmen sie mal die
pille fein früher lösung für anderes
wenn es probleme gibt alleine die sechs
minuten nur über die pille und da hast
du noch gar nicht angesprochen was ist
das vorher noch gibt die pille ich meine
ja mittlerweile über 150 bis 200
verschiedenste arten von pillen ahnung
hast du denn eine auswahl an präparaten
video verschreibt also wenn jemand
kompletter ist oder was auch immer
migräne hat muss ich etwas ganz anderes
wählen als wenn jemand schlanke und es
kommt natürlich auch die problematik
auch anders das treibt mich überhaupt
dazu eine politische schreiben ich habe
das gefühl ich hab selber relativ wenig
wissen an die hand bekommen von meinen
gegnerinnen damals und habe später in
mir selbst ein eigenes wissen so ein
bisschen an geeignet bin auch erstmal so
in richtung gerutscht wo ich dachte
jetzt einfach nur noch angst also
beispielsweise war es so dass ich mich
lange zeit gefragter kapelle durch
nehmen oder hat diese blutung der
zwischenklasse stellt sich ja irgendwie
heraus sind kein nutzen soll also dieser
medizinische sinne gibt es nicht hinter
dieser abbruch blutung weil es für
diesen abbruch und aufbau erlaubt keinen
grund gibt ganz im gegenteil es schlecht
er noch das system es heißt auch nicht
dass du funktionierst oder irgendwas das
heißt auch nicht dass du gereinigt wird
das heißt einfach nur dort eine
gebärmutter da wird schon einmal
künstlich aufgebaut und die bluttat das
war damals tatsächlich für die
katholische kirche also dieses gerücht
stimmt weil man natürlich den
katholiken ja so ein bisschen
schmackhafter machen will die frau hat
natürlichen zyklus ab blutung alles so
wie immer medizinischen zweck hat sie
gar nicht und die neuesten generationen
der pille gehen auch dahin dass man sie
quasi durch nimmt man macht sich diese
künstliche station zu nutzen zum
beispiel eine endometriose also ganz
schlimm chronischen erkrankungen da
möchte ich dass kein biologischer zyklus
da ist für diese frauen ist die pille
ein segen muss man wirklich sagen also
die haben keine schmerzen mehr hat ihnen
geht es besser aber sie darf nicht mehr
so oft gegeben werden ist vielleicht vor
20 jahren aber dann verabschieden wir
uns sehr viel spaß
[Musik]
muss seinen eindruck nach dem besuch
spannende irgendwann das normal ist
damit die ziele schluss sich zu sehen
wie ging es dir dass du der richtige maß
gekürzt ich bin mir sogar rasch von den
grünen besuchen die ich hab das da mir
das nicht weiter verletzt wurde deswegen
frage ich immer so viel weil ich wenn
ich auch wissen möchte wie geht ist für
alle künste woran liegt das jetzt hat er
sehr deutlich gemacht dass es vor in das
problem liegt nämlich in einem haus auf
virtuelle euro vieten augenbrauen im
system und eben nicht an einzelpersonen
oder in dem das wissen nicht da ist
sondern das ist einfach dass die zeit
nicht da ist um es weiter zu geben dass
sich die zeit nicht genommen wird um es
weiter zu geben ja aber ich bin gespannt
wo sie uns jetzt noch her dass man hier
jetzt noch auf ein neues abenteuer ok
mitten im wald wir sind mitten im wald
das machen wir mitten im wald aber es
ist cool es kühler ich sehe jemand
erwartet ihr uns jemand in sich gehen
wir spazieren da kommt jemand
jetzt treffen wir
schon nichts
weißt du was uns heute hier zusammen
bringt deshalb wir aufeinander treffen
ich glaube verhüten oder vielleicht
magst du uns erzählen
wie du zum thema klingt ist oder verfügt
und ich hab halt persönlich
negative erfahrungen gemacht mit der
pille ich habe halt so mit 13 14 glaube
ich verschrieben bekommen und also das
gespräch bei meinem frauen als belief
sich auf na ja vielleicht hast du dann
auch weniger pickel und dann hatte ich
erst die minipille
und da wurde mir halt auch erzählt okay
ist so gering dosiert und merkt man kaum
was von und dann habe ich eineinhalb
jahre lang ich habe keinen appetit mehr
und ich habe super viel gewicht verloren
und dann bin ich wieder zum freiheits
gegangen hat er mit andere pille
verschrieben also normale filme und hier
habe ich dann auch genommen bissig 22
war glaube ich und irgendwann habe ich
gemerkt ich habe jeden tag kopfschmerzen
also wirklich jeden tag ein tage nämlich
keine kopfschmerzen hatte und ich habe
migräne bekommen die ich vorher nicht
hatte die stimmungsschwankungen ich
hatte manchmal das gefühl ich bin so ein
ferngesteuertes auto
aber ich habe selbst die die
fernbedienung in der hand und dann
irgendwann habe ich die pille abgesetzt
und es war als wird so ein schleier von
mir genommen und ich ja so als hätte ich
in seiner badewanne gestanden und jemand
hat den stöpsel gezogen und ganze
dreckige wasser ist eigentlich
abgelaufen ich habe wahnsinnig stark pms
und
das habe ich jetzt halt auch wieder ich
nehme jetzt wo gott nicht
67 jahren gar keine hormone mehr und ich
habe seitdem halt wieder gms und es ist
auch wirklich schlimm und es
beeinträchtigt weil eben auch würde ich
sagen aber es sind halt drei von vier
wochen im monat wo es nicht so gut geht
und mit der pille weil es halt jeden tag
wo es menschliche obwohl die fälle das
einzige ist was gegen perm ist geholfen
hat bei mir deswegen sehe ich halt auch
wirklich den nutzen der wende und
verstehen dass so viele gut funktioniert
aber diese nebenwirkung und dieses
gefühl dass ich nicht ich selbst bin war
so schlimm dass ich lieber das pms
aushalte als die polarisation
fühlst du dich guten händen viele
sportarten gehandelt 0 ich habe
irgendwann selbstständig entschieden und
ich setze das jetzt alles ab ich war
dann als ich so krank war ich war so
unfassbar vielen verschiedenen ärzten
und ärzten und was halt immer kam war
immer erst die frage wie sieht es denn
wir sitzen bei ihm im elternhaus aus
haben sie beruflich viel stress
na ja viele bilden sich das ja auch ein
und es war also ich bin jedes mal
frustriert nach hause gekommen ich hab
ich habe hilfe gesucht und habe einfach
wolltest du schon immer haben ja es
wurde jetzt angekündigt eben als antwort
auf diesen trend liegen hormone an
hormon freien willen weiter zu forschen
und daran zu setzen
wie seht ihr das würdet ihr das
ausprobieren eine neue pille die hormone
frei funktionieren soll ich bin ich aus
prinzip gegen jede art von hormonen ich
weiß dass es bei mir halt überhaupt
nicht funktioniert hat deswegen klar
dass neue screens würde ich schon mal
gucken
ich glaube auch wirklich das ideale wäre
quasi dass beide menschen in einer
partnerschaft hat sich dass beide sich
irgendwie verhütung kümmern können ohne
dass eine der beiden personen extrem
konsequenzen tragen alles würden trägt
ganz genau danke dir dass du so vertraut
hast du deine geschichte
[Musik]
wir gehen wieder in unseren wenn
ich bin traurig zu sagen
[Musik]
ich finde es mega gut und wichtig dass
wir jetzt nochmal mit niemandem
gesprochen hat die da auch so kasse
persönlich ein persönlicher erfahrung
gemacht wenn ich finde es wieder so
krass rausgekommen ist ist das einfach
das so oft bagatellisiert wird dass die
leute nicht ernst genommen werden mit
denen beschwerden mit ihren wünschen und
das macht ein richtig wütend eigentlich
ich glaube dass wir mit der bisher
gegebenen ausfall uns nicht zufrieden
geben soll
den gerichten zu verfügen es braucht
einfach mehr möglichkeiten für alle
menschen unabhängig von geschlecht
ich glaube ein paar dinge gibt es auf
die wir uns auf jeden fall einigen
können und zwar dass es mehr
alternativen geben muss dass das braucht
mehr forschung in dem bereich es braucht
mehr gelder die in die forschung fließen
wir waren uns einig darin dass man auch
geld reinstecken muss das gynäkologinnen
die leute besser beraten können und
individuelle beraten können ja und was
schon viel früher anzusetzen auch in der
schule schon viel umfangreicheres wissen
zu vermitteln weg zu gehen von tabus und
wegzugehen von tradierten
geschlechterrollen und so erkennen dass
es sich dabei um alles andere als
privatsache handelt sondern echt um ein
sehr wichtiges politisches thema und
dass wir sie nur lösen können wenn wir
alle zusammenarbeiten wo wir uns nicht
ganz einig sind
ist die pille noch zeitgemäß ich weiß
nicht ob es auf diese frage für mich
gibt es nach wie vor keine standard
antwort würde ich schon mich ist es
keine klare antwort auch jetzt nach
diesem tag nicht für mich ist der umgang
mit füllung nicht zeitgemäß dass man
standardmäßig die pille verschreibt aus
all den gründen die wir heute genannt
haben und gesehen und gehört haben dass
es alles andere als zeitgemäß für mich
ist und wir das stecken geblieben in dem
mindset der 60er jahre und da muss ich
dringend was tun da muss ich auf jeden
fall dringend was tun magdalena ich fand
es einfach nur mega für diesen tag heute
welche folgen
zu sehen
wie seht ihr das ist die pille noch
zeitgemäß schreibt es uns in die
kommentare
warum es immer noch keine pille für den
mann gibt und wie gut die
pharmaindustrie seit jahren an der
hormon pille verdient das zeigen wir in
der doku sex pille und das große geld
auch hier sprechen wir mit allen seiten
und zeigen beim thema verhütung die
grauzonen klickt einfach hier und schaut
den film in der zdf mediathek
[Musik]